[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and this week the focus is on
German Chancellor Angela Merkel who
truly has her back to the wall everyone
is asking how long can Europe's
longest-serving leader cling on to
office and with the latest ructions over
Germany's and Europe's immigration
policy Merkel is facing an ultimatum
from her powerful interior minister
horses a whole fir says bring back a
European solution from the Brussels
summit at the end of the month or else
he will go it alone
at issue a unilateral order for police
to start turning away refugees from
Germany's borders so our question here
on quadriga germany's refugee Rauh can
merkel survive and to discuss that
question I'm joined in the studio by
three journalists who've all been
following this story closely beginning
with Pascal tee-ball berlin
correspondent for audio france antony
sayonara
Pascal believes that Merkel's crisis
will only bring France and Germany
closer together the struggling
Chancellor is dependent on support from
Paris also with his Allen Posen a
regular columnist for the Berlin daily
de Velde who says once again Merkel has
defeated an opponent by giving him just
enough rope to hang himself with horse a
hoofer talk the talk but couldn't and a
very warm welcome to town as they are
ahead of the opinions section at another
Berlin paper dare Targa Spiegel Anna
believes Angela Merkel is a survivor but
she is now at the mercy of Europe's
populist s' and I let me begin with you
it's been described as the biggest
crisis of the Merkel years that is
surely no exaggeration no it is not it
is a very deep crisis though we have
talked about deep crises for she has
always survived this show and I think
she still has a chance to get out of
this one decently I think there is the
possibility for compromise but yet both
maca and V hofa are in it with all they
have with their very causes of political
existence so I think it is it is very
two giants in the
stages of their political careers Alan
you write for develop newspapers I've
said as a columnist but you've already
had a piece you've all also had a piece
in the week Teague in The Guardian in
the UK this week
saying no one can deny that Angela
Merkel's Coalition is in trouble how
deep is the trouble well it is in
trouble I know but I don't think the
trouble is as deep as it's made out to
be I think there's a you could say in a
way that's a wolf and Marco are playing
good cop bad cop or bad cop good cop
Marco being the good cop see hoping the
being the bad cop but essentially
pulling on the same rope if you see if
you said I mean because well look
firstly um talking about rope Z who
forgave Michael an ultimatum to come
round to his position or he would impose
border controls unilaterally by last
Monday land Monday came and went and
nothing happened except that they
overextended his outer matron two to two
weeks
so Marco could get us the courage of his
conviction he he's yes he's already
climbed down and he hasn't really said
if you don't get what I want I will do
this he has said he will be back well
people say that don't they he's climbed
down he's proved that he's really just a
cuddly teddy bear and not a roaring lion
horse is a [ __ ] a cuddly teddy bear
Shambala ng pasko t boy is this a crisis
about Angela Merkel's coalition
government is it a crisis about Angela
Merkel or is it a crisis about the
future of the Europe both I think yeah
there is a crisis in this coalition I
think this coalition is a crisis since
its birth that's my it's birth that's my
impression because it was so difficult
and it's quite it's quite obvious that
they are going I think to struggle
during four years if it's if this
government lasts four for four years and
it's a crisis of course in Europe
because it's probably the it's it's the
most important crisis since the
financial and economical crisis at the
end of the
of the last decade and this time the
victim could possibly be a miracle we
will see if it's possible for her it's
almost it's incredible how much she has
to solve in the next week on the next 10
days if she will find a compromise with
some partners but the situation is worse
than it was with populist parties in in
some governments in Europe so it's it's
almost an impossible mission mission
impossible you said this week you broke
a lance for Angela Merkel and Erin you
said she deserves our respect just
explain a little bit more why she
deserves our respect
I think the csus finally giving in to
being a populist party or at least
performing populist strategies and that
is pretending there still is a crisis
and pretending there still is an
enormous potential crisis what crisis I
mean the number is a political process
yes yes no but it's a it's an artificial
crisis because they have created it
because the numbers of the silent
seekers have been going down with the
turkey deal and and other measures
strengthened in frontex in the
Mediterranean working with the Libyan
Coast Guard the the refugees are
actually pushed back behind the
Mediterranean so Mecca has created time
to discuss and find a strategy with the
European partners it's going to take
time and now she's in a very bad
position because now she has to find a
solution within two weeks and I like the
idea of them playing good cop bad cop
but I think it's rather hurting her
position to discuss and negotiate with
the European partners which are very
difficult as we know you don't buy this
Ellen well no I think you know if she
goes if Matt Rocco goes to some European
partners he doesn't have to go to the
mall because you know the visi grad
states basically aren't part of the
equation they're not taking any refugees
anyway
they also don't have any outside border
so she has to basically deal with
Austria Italy France Belgium and so on
and and just
a lion a lion in my car and she has
allies in Belgium and Holland and she
can say to the Italians look I've got
this fiery dragon breathing down my neck
help me and then they'll say okay how
much you're gonna pay and to [ __ ] up in
some way yeah but you don't have to pay
more because she's an enormous time
pressure and we see that now with my car
and and the common European budget that
maybe she has to put in some more so he
helps her keep the the migrants out when
you say pay up the payments of cash
payment so we're talking about
payments from made by Germany or
payments from European Union funds
no I mean the payments in a not in a
literal sense with when she comes to
terms with Italy or somebody else about
taking the migrants back there might be
payments involved over help people are
beginning to talk about this I think she
also said in the press conference with
Mike on Tuesday she spoke in a very
light way about financial compensations
yes like Italy because we heard in the
meantime that the interior minister in
in Italy salvini doesn't want him he's
migrans back so maybe the way to let him
accept them is to give him some money
and it could be probably a way on Sunday
in Brussels for America to to achieve a
compromise with Italy and other
countries okay things have now certainly
come to a head but the animosity between
Angela Merkel and her interior minister
horsey Hoffer that we've been talking
about goes back a long way let's just
get a glimpse of how acrimonious it has
been the rift between Angela Merkel and
hosta Hoffa began to develop in 2015
when the miracle government opened
Germany's borders to 1 million refugees
we've done so much we can do this listen
amigo this is a huge undertaking which
is now been exacerbated by this decision
new spreads quickly around the world we
can do this I can only repeat the system
is collapsing the beauty the dispute has
now escalated with zero first demand to
turn refugees away we think that as a
country at the heart of Europe turning
people back at our borders without
consultation could lead to negative
Domino effects that could hurt Germany
skin I say that if there are no such
effects I am determined that migrants
must be turned back at our border since
this request
what does horse say Hoffa really want
stricter Asylum laws or to topple the
Chancellor
stricter asylum laws or toppling the
Chancellor alum water - what does horse
a hoofer really want neither no I don't
know no look he says in your reports
it's about turning migrants back at the
border first it's not it's about turning
certain groups of migrants back those
who have applied for asylum in Germany
been turned down eh and those who've
been registered in other countries both
are as we speak being turned back
already and have been turned back for a
long time this year alone sent back to
to roll in in in in Austria the province
of Tyrolean 700 people who fall into
this category we send back our Bane
Ian's in by the thousands because they
don't have enough money with them or
because their passport is not
biometrically aligned with European law
so this happens all the time so the
officer came on this it's happening and
it's gonna go on happening it's it's all
it's like it when the begin of the
refugee crisis when a million came in he
said I demand an upper limit of 200,000
refugees we now don't even have 200,000
refugees coming every year so he's he
has this big sort of I'm demanding this
but actually he's again he's more or
less a cuddly bear you know his his bark
is much much worse than his bite Pascal
cuddly bear he may or may not be but he
has delivered an ultimatum to the German
Chancellor what's going on here that a
minister albeit a senior minister is -
is putting the gun to the head of the
German Chancellor and being quoted as
saying I can't work with that woman any
longer what is going on yeah it's quite
incredible yeah especially the German
political mean I would I would maybe
maybe we could hear such remarks maybe
in other countries which are not so so
stable like Germany so it's a it's a bit
surprising for some somebody coming from
France but I think it shows also how how
difficult the relations is but we are we
speak also about about symbols I think
we have already read heard about the the
the figures I think 0fo needs to show a
stronger
politics
from aggression but I think there is a
lot of symbolic in his politics and also
because of the situation in Bavaria
because of the elections in in October
and because of the concurrence of the
right-wing party alternativa photo
channel so I think quite a lot is is
also quite a lot of his politic is also
a show but of course the for the image
if this was soccer people are talking
about soccer a lot these days people
would be saying it's a grudge match
their horse 2:04 clearly bears a grudge
against Angela Merkel from the way she
behaved towards him and with him in 2015
it's not just the cuddly bear theory no
lots of men bear grudges against Angela
Merkel and up till now she's managed to
serve off [ __ ] off every single one of
them there you know there was a German
there was a Italian cowboy western movie
which was called in German lifeless
turns on vague bodies plaster his his
path that's market and the overs gonna
be the next come on he's not going to
get what he wants I could hear you
drawing breath he's not the only one I I
wouldn't just cut it down to the Makah
0-5 antagonism it's the whole party
that's behind the hofa and other people
in the party like Marco sudha whom he
lost to and Alexander homeand he's a
biter and they are pushing him they are
putting the the poor cuddly bear to go
after miracle and sitting in Bavaria
Munich and laughing their heads off so
it's a process of generational change in
conservative politics in Germany and for
my money it's a process there's a new
political culture emerging on the
conservative side of German politics
yeah I mean you can see it in the in the
Conservatives in in Bavaria but there's
also groups within the Christian
Democratic Union for pushing for more
conservative politics and of course is
there something to do with the
right-wing party we have in the
Bundestag they are very determined
particularly DuPont and others to win
back those votes from the aft
and they coached house all the time
there should not be a transformative
Aryan leader there should not be a party
right of the Christian Democratic Union
or its Bavarian branch and that's what
they are going after and I think they
really believe that I think they these
voters belong to them and they want them
back and of course it's not good for a
conservative revolution yes some some
health and I don't think the group I
don't know for Bavaria but within the
Christian Democratic Union I think this
is a minority group there they're not
that large and right now the the party
is still behind Uncle America as we have
seen in in the meetings of the caucus at
the Bundestag and and other meetings
they're still backing her but yes there
is the process of change and and we see
the faces that are coming up like
against ban for example who do want
another the angry young man of
conservative politics of the moment 37
years old I think is in yeah Health
Minister yeah
talks about as possible Chancellor
material in the future let's go are the
are the right-wing populists s-- taking
over in Europe they sense that they've
got the wind at their backs now yeah
that's true we can see it in several
countries in Germany they are in the
Parliament as we have already heard
there did take part and the government
in Austria in Italy and and they have
also they have also had some successes
in other countries so it's it's also a
sign that probably the European ID and
is not convincing the people and that
national solutions are for more people
in Europe the better way to solve
problems I think it's an error of course
but that's a very problematic solution
and of course it's a big responsibility
for the our leaders to show it is
possible to find your punishment but
what but for the migration topic it is
it is almost impossible I mean we we
have these we have these different is
back differences between the Western
European countries and the Eastern
European countries and we have also the
difficulties especially with Italy with
new government with the right-wing
environment not willing to accept for
example the migrants which because of
the Dublin agreement should go back to
Italy so it's the National card if we
can if we can use this this expression
is his plays a very great role that
nowadays absolutely
I wonder Alan what the new right want
I've got a I wrote down a quote from the
CSU's mark asserted we'd been talking
about Marcus odor from from Bavaria
Bavarian conservative he called this
week for the or he described this as the
end of the era of orderly
multilateralism translated and this is
not just semantics that seems to mean to
me that what he is propagating is the
beginning of an era of unordinary on
orderly unilateralism that is a whole
sea change that is a move away from the
post-war consensus liberal values based
politics what I think he means of meant
though wizard it's difficult to say what
I think he meant was within Europe the
idea that Europe moves so to speak in
lockstep it's it's obvious that that's
not the case no one wants to join the
eurozone anymore for instance because
they seen what happened to Greece and in
in in the the Hungarians are leading a
revolt against migration with the visa
grad group of four who are meeting today
I think too with the Austrians by the
way to to combine their policies to
coordinate their anti-immigration
policies and on the other hand there's
the if you will old EU but there again
some differences so what matters right
so what we're seeing is it instead of
the EU deciding something together you
have different groups within the you
deciding things that is not disorderly
unilateral
that is slightly disorderly four five
six speed Europe but it's it's still
possible I mean that's the way it goes
you're not going to get a united Europe
the way it was before we enlarged to
these that's not gonna happen
Donald Trump waded into the debate this
way what did you make of that Anna well
I you could see it as an attempt to
destabilize Germany and overthrow Angela
maca I don't think it was that he
tweeted and I think it was largely the
the major reason was the internal
problems he has with a huge backlash
against the policies of separating
families at the Mexican border so he has
done it before he has often pointed to
Europe as for for the illustration of
failed migration policies he has done
that pointing to Sweden he has done it
to pointing to Germany before and I
think that's just covering his hardline
which is no there are serious voices
here in Europe who are saying look we've
got this growing in front of a far-right
populist opinion across Europe and one
end you've got a bloody mere Putin at
the other end you've got Donald Trump
and that looks like a threatening
scenario for lily-livered liberals yes
it is and I mean the American ambassador
to Germany has said he wants to promote
conservative movements in Germany and
has pointed to quit but it was very
obvious from his wording that he was
meaning the right-wing populist too so
this is there is an alignment between
those groups I just don't think that's
what Trump hinted at with his tweet okay
well earlier this week French president
Emmanuel macron and German Chancellor
Angela Merkel met for talks in the
German government guest house north of
Berlin commentators say that the two
leaders are more dependent on each other
than ever before macron leads Merkel for
his ambitious plans to press ahead with
a more federal Europe Merkel needs my
chrome to come up with a pan-european
migration solution Pascal do you still
trust in the Merkel
macro access that it attended that they
will in effect save the liberal Europe
we are France and Germany are two
countries among 27 or 28th or 19 for the
eurozone so it's much more difficult
than it was in the past for these two to
impose compromises and it's more
difficult not only because of the number
of the Member States but also because of
the divisions we have already talked
about in the European Union and in the
euro zone but if there are no or if the
if Michael and Michael don't make
proposals we will make them so I think
what they achieved in in mez burg is is
a compromise more euro zone meters
especially with the with the budget for
this zone it was a very important symbol
or measure for Michael going to be a
huge budget yeah we don't know exactly
but probably that but we see and that's
why of that wise also we we they didn't
gather that even they didn't say how
much this budget will be because because
because it's there are still they're
difficult to find a compromise between
france and germany and nowadays because
of the migration problem miracle needs
more than in the past the support of
france we have a situation between the
two countries which is absolutely the
contrary than it was 15 15 months ago
with a weak french partner with francois
hollande
with the with the situation in which it
was impossible more or less to have
common proposals and now we have Macomb
becoming more or less the leader of the
integrated Europe and Merkel which is
the who is the the weak partner who need
nowadays the support of France I know
what's going to happen next in German
politics we've got a pretty sort of
strict timetable now we've got the
Brussels summit coming up and that's
going to it's it's a make-or-break kind
of a summit
at least what is being suggested what
happens next I am I don't know what
where the whole fuh and his pals in
Bavaria a heading for I don't know how
crazy they are whether they really want
to push it to this so they want Merkel
out until they have an alternative I
think there will be a compromise I think
he will accept what she negotiates
bilaterally with Italy hopefully and
others so both get what they want you
will be able to turn away more people at
the border she will have a European
solution and I think then they will try
to move on
exactly as I say but the move has
already lost it's just a question of
saving face by the way if you saw them
both yesterday there was this
celebration of our anniversary of it was
all about about refugees German refugees
from from the east and so on and Mackel
but it's not uncomfortably next to each
other yes battle got enormous applause
from the assembled political and
cultural elites of Germany and she has
this behind her back and Zi hua is an
outsider and he'll have to climb down
what scar yeah I think okay into the
crystal ball we will see if the offer is
able to survive politically as a
minister after the Bavarian elections
maybe it has to resign or not but I
think also is a more or less yeah
symbolic personality but I think he's
already more or less is an old older man
and I think probably he will it will
sometime leave the the political scene
in Berlin
[Music]
maybe we have more time to play with
little strains in his in his house at
home another another film title format
was evil for the walking dead
[Laughter]
I noticed Allen that you talked in the
guardian item that I hear that I quoted
earlier you talked about what has been
what there has been in Germany you
described as a Viognier lien gutter
Denver wrong frenzy this week yeah
you're sticking by that
yeah I'm seeking Matt because you know I
mean look we journalists we love sort of
to to to to call out the end of the
world and great crisis and so on every
time this happens they sort of jump
Europe now is finally the end and of
course some day it's gonna be the end of
Merkel I mean she doesn't isn't gonna
rain forever long to reign over us
that's the British National Ignition a
platinum that's not ours but come on
it's not today it's not tomorrow you're
all free so sane and sensible I know so
shall we shall say anyway there when you
talked about the British there stay calm
carry on that seems to be the message
from quadriga this week we've been
discussing Germany's refugee rel
canonical survive bye-bye
[Music]